humans are built to serve you want to
help people it's hardwired into US
serving other people touches the same
part of our brain as eating food and
having sex you need it but how do you
serve what is your purpose how do you
find your passion so earlier this year I
went across 90 days 23 cities across the
U.S on a tour speaking tour in my head
my plan was to talk about how to
overcome judgment how to take the two
percent difference and just start acting
on your ideas and as I started getting
more questions the single thing that
came up over and over again from 23
different cities across the entire
country from Pittsburgh to San Diego and
back was how do I find my purpose and in
every single City I had to walk people
through this process and because it
became so important I started to write a
book on it because I basically went
through interventions with people where
I had them stand up and had them go
through a three-step process and they
got a result and suddenly after years or
Decades of no Clarity they had Clarity
on what they should be doing and what
their purpose was what their passion was
and what their path forward was need
motivation the top 10 will believe
Nation hey it's Nina Carmichael we made
these videos because you're probably the
most ambitious person in your circle but
you know you're capable of much more and
you get that Push by surrounding
yourself with the best so today let's
learn from one of the best my husband
Evan Carmichael and his top 10 rules for
Success enjoy
Step One is who step two is why and step
three is how so let's start with step
one it's your who it's your most
important core value humans are built
off of core values and is one that's
more important than all the others if
you had to decide what is your single
most important core value what is it you
may not know exactly but you're gonna
get pretty close just just go down this
thought exercise for now what is one
important core value that you hold that
if if people around you were the
opposite of it it would be toxic to you
it's important to figure out because
when people don't know what their most
important core value is you get pulled
into a whole bunch of different
directions you get pulled to follow
somebody else's purpose somebody else's
Mission and settle for it but what
you're settling for is crumbs it's
crumbs of purpose because it's their
purpose that you're just kind of helping
instead of you actually living your
purpose makes a massive difference it
starts with what is your single most
important core value and you can look at
that by what are all the things that
have made you come alive in the past the
people you love the relationship that's
worked out that the thing you learn from
your teachers the most why you love
those people so much is a Common Thread
and when you figure that out it allows
you to build a better life and business
going forward with intention around your
most important core value and bringing
people alongside your mission to support
you so you're working with the people
who are like-minded instead of having a
random assortment of people who might
have great skills with different values
and it doesn't work out step two is your
why this is your purpose your purpose
comes from your pain your purpose comes
from your pain think about the most
painful moment you had growing up in
your past it doesn't have to be from
eight years old maybe it was something
that happened two years ago but the most
painful moment in your life what was it
well you felt not physical pain but
emotional pain that you felt worthless
as a human being when did you feel the
most worthless as a human being that
moment
helping other people is built into you
right humans are built to serve but
helping people who are exactly like that
will be the people that you love helping
for the rest of your life
because whether that was two years ago
five years ago 20 years ago let's just
say it was five years ago for this
example the person who you were five
years ago you've grown a lot since then
you may not be out of the woods you may
not have figured it all out you're still
on your journey you're still learning
and growing and you never want to stop
learning and growing but you're way
better than you used to be you're way
better than you were five years ago now
there's a lot of people who are exactly
who you used to be five years ago and
they're struggling and they need help
and they need guidance and they're
afraid and they don't know what to do
you can help them
just like the version of you right now
could go back five years and help the
person who used to be there are a lot of
people who are what you used to be they
currently are what you used to be
you can help them and helping them it's
not just a matter of you can
it'll fill you up it'll never get old
for the rest of your life your purpose
comes from your pain and in step three
is your how this is your passion so how
did you get out of it how did you solve
the problem again you might not be
totally out of the woods you're still
learning and growing amazing but you've
learned a lot since the person you were
five years ago how did you get out of it
what did you do
was it watching YouTube videos was it
meditation was it getting in shape
eating better food what was it what did
you do what did you do to save yourself
that was not a random occurrence that
was not something that can just work for
you that's a recipe that you can apply
to help other people as well the path
that you took to get out or at least get
a little bit better than where you used
to be is something that is teachable
that you can help other people with as
well and give them hope and give them
momentum and give them confidence and
again that will fill you up for the rest
of your life rule number two ignore the
opinions of others your fear of other
people's judgment is the single biggest
Factor holding back the success of your
life you want to serve others humans are
built to serve others you need it it's
your purpose but serving requires
someone else and as long as you're
worried about that person's judgment and
opinion of you you will stay still and
never act so you've got one foot on the
brake and one foot on the gas pushing
hard spinning your wheels and never
going anywhere knowing that you're
capable of a lot more but afraid to take
action I don't tell a lot of stories
about my parents they had a huge impact
on my life they're here on the wall
behind me I'm eight or nine years old
and that's them above me they're really
private people so I I keep the stories
that I share about them to a minimum but
one of my favorites are when I was in
school I was in art class and the
teacher told me to do a project and he
said paint a window and so I painted a
window and then I added a sailboat and I
added sunshine and I paint I had had
some curtains and I had a lot more to
the painting and I failed the assignment
because the teacher said I asked you to
paint a window and you did all this
other stuff and so my parents went into
school
later on and said hey uh what was the
assignment that you asked Evan to do and
said well paint the window I was like
well he clearly painted the window I
mean he did what you told him to do and
and they they stood up and became a
shield for me and I was blessed to have
an amazing parents you might have
amazing parents you might not it doesn't
matter either way but
wherever you learn and however you learn
you have to learn it that you need to go
off and express yourself you need to go
off and create the thing that you want
to create even if the rules tell you
that you can't do it even if your
teachers tell you that that's crazy even
if your parents tell you you'll never
make it and they want you to do
something safe and practical you have to
do it because otherwise you're teaching
yourself to play small and that
permeates for life you have ideas you're
a genius you've got Michael Jordan level
Talent or something you should be off
creating amazing things but you're
afraid because of other people's
judgment and as long as that is the
thing that is in the back of your head
that you're not afraid of failing you're
afraid of failing in front of somebody
else you'll sing in the shower but you
won't sing on the street because you're
afraid of what other people are going to
think about you and as long as that is
the reason why you're not taking action
then you lose for Life rule number three
do difficult things you love difficult
things you do difficult things are
amazing difficult things are the best
difficult things are the only way that
you grow think about it what's the
opposite of difficult easy safe inside
your comfort zone boring the single
greatest thing that you can ever do for
your confidence is teach yourself that
when things get difficult you don't
shrink down you rise to the occasion so
in my keynote presentations I used to
always use slides as well I had
PowerPoint up and and I wouldn't read
the text off of the slides but I have a
picture and I tell a story about it and
it would always keep me focused on where
my presentation was going
and then I got offered to do a speaking
gig in Paris I was the keynote speech at
this big event for this software company
and I was gonna close the show for them
and I had this idea in my head that what
if I didn't do slides what if I spoke on
stage for I forget how long 45 minutes
to an hour closing Keynote
and I just had one slide and it was a
picture of a rabbit because I was
telling a story but trying to teach a
rabbit to climb a tree and it scared me
I thought it's difficult and because
that's what I thought that I had to do
it because in my head is well what if I
don't remember where I go what if I
forget the stories what if I lose track
of where I'm at and I'm sitting here on
stage the closing keynote been paid all
this money to come and I just suck
and because that was the reason that I
had to do it I had to do it and so I
said I'm just gonna have one slide
and when the tech team said hey what do
you want to show on screen here it is
it's just one slide yep no videos nope
no audio nope one slide that's it put
that up and I practice and I practice
and I practice and and because my
greatest fear in the world disappointing
people I probably over practice and have
my speech down and I went and crushed it
but even if I didn't it was the
willingness to try it's the willingness
to do difficult things that as soon as
you feel yourself playing potentially
small based off of something being
difficult that means it's go time that
means you have to do it because teaching
yourself that you think of something
that's big and scary and then you crouch
down and you shy away and you don't do
that that's that's an ongoing lesson
that you were teaching yourself that you
suck you're telling yourself if I went
and said hmm what about doing just one
slide in France right for my Paris
keynote what if it's just one slide and
I'm scared of it and I don't do it I'm
teaching myself that I suck that's what
you do anytime you approach something
big and you don't do it you're telling
yourself you're not capable you're
telling yourself that you suck and so
everybody else might let you off the
hook you may not even tell anybody else
about this crazy idea that you have but
you playing small is not acceptable when
something is difficult you have to
attack it head on rule number four be
your biggest critic and fan what do you
say when you see yourself in the mirror
when it's just you when you're all alone
it's just you you see yourself in the
mirror what do you say do you say great
things or do you beat yourself up most
people they might act confident and seem
like they have it all put together but
secretly they're fighting their own
battles and at home in private the
comfort of their own home they're their
own worst enemies the secret is to be
your own biggest critic as well as your
biggest fan the push you give yourself
has to be from a place of love and
potential not lack and despair so I
recently posted on Instagram a little
cartoon of me passing by a mirror and
you see my reflection in the mirror and
the caption says I love you and then I
challenge people to say hey what do you
what do you say to yourself when you
look in the mirror and giving them an
18-day challenge to say every time you
see a reflection of yourself to say
something positive whether it's I love
you or give yourself a compliment
something positive because I think most
people live in the land of negativity
all we see is all the negative things
that we're doing and all the things that
didn't work out and things that could
have been better and that can actually
be very healthy I think you need to be
your own biggest critic I think you need
to have higher standards for yourself
than what you're currently doing but it
only works being your own biggest critic
only works when it's based off a
foundation of love
when it's based off a foundation of I am
an amazing human being and I love myself
and I suck at all of these skills the
problem that most people have is you see
that you suck at a scale that you didn't
get the result that you're not good on
camera the first time you go out you
didn't get the result you didn't land
the sale you didn't make the deal you
didn't get the date you know whatever it
is you didn't get the result and then
you think that you suck as a human
because you don't have the skills it's
the opposite you're you're amazing as a
human it has to be from a foundation of
love that you love yourself and that you
suck at the skills and then you can beat
yourself up over how they might get
better how do I improve how do I acquire
the skills how do I move forward towards
my goal also to make sure you're
actually taking action after watching
this video I designed a special free
worksheet just for this video the
worksheet will highlight all the Lessons
Learned in this video as well as pull
out our three favorite learnings and
quotes that will inspire you to actually
do something the worksheet will also
give you space to write down what your
key takeaways are and your specific plan
of action to make sure you're getting
results if you want the worksheet
designed specifically for this video
absolutely for free there's a link in
the description below go click on it and
start building the momentum in your life
and your business I'll see you there
rule number five Raise your environment
your environment has been perfectly
created to keep you exactly where you
are everything around you your friends
your family the media you consume all
keeps you exactly where you are if you
want to raise your standards and raise
the quality of your life it starts with
raising your environment so here's a
story I haven't told in a while when I
was building up my YouTube channel and I
closed my first multi-year deal with the
Big Brand it was with a CEO high-powered
CEO one of the largest companies in the
world especially in The Entrepreneur
Space and it was going to be me and him
on my channel every month answering
questions from you guys from the
audience we did a live stream every
month and it wasn't me interviewing him
or him interviewing me it was both of us
talking about a certain topic and then
taking questions and I remember driving
with my dad he was getting a new car and
we had this long drive out for whatever
reason the place we wanted to buy the
car was super far away and so it gave us
this chance to talk in a car and I just
told him about this this new deal that I
had signed I remember him asking me Evan
what gives you the confidence to feel
like you're on the same level as this
guy and he didn't mean it in a in a
negative way it was it was in a more
austruck way it's like man look at where
you've come from because my family is
very humble like you have to be very
humble you have to appreciate what
you've got and so how am I now how do I
see myself on the same stage as this
high-powered CEOs being his equal
answering questions
and the question took me back and I
thought you know what he's right I mean
if this was Evan of five years prior I
would have felt not worthy I would have
felt like I couldn't do it I would have
felt like this is too big an opportunity
for me like I couldn't be the guy to do
it so what changed five years ago to
where I was at that point it was my
content it was my channel it was all the
videos that I'm I'm putting up because
in my head it was a big deal in that
this is the largest deal I had signed
for three years but more of that I'm
around Oprah every day and and then
paying you every day and Kanye West
every day and all these people every day
and so I feel like I'm with them
and and so this CEO deal wasn't that
huge a deal
because I had changed my environment
right I'd raised the stakes in my
environment and that raises your
standards and so I realized man this is
crazy how important my channel is to
myself at least to my own growth if it's
not to you at least to my own growth
because you often can't see it on a
daily basis I could not pinpoint the one
video I uploaded or the one day that I
felt this is it it's happened
but if I look back over a five-year
period a one-year period a six-month
period even a three month period think
about who you were three months ago if
you're invested in yourself by watching
these videos or reading books or
anything else if you're investing in
yourself even just look three months
back and think have I grown how much
have you grown in the past three months
you may not see it on a daily basis but
with months and then more months and
then more months and then years if you
keep on the path you'll see some
tremendous results may not even
recognize the person who you used to be
and that's why it's so important you
raise your environment rule number six
get
your goals you even
or you are afraid of them you might just
not want to do them you might be in the
wrong thing you might have picked the
wrong goals for the wrong reasons or
you're afraid of your goals you're
afraid of failing you're afraid of it
not working out and what that means
either way the answer is action if you
don't love it move on immediately and if
you're afraid of it move into it
immediately focused action is always the
answer so one of the entrepreneurs that
I've invested into his name is Alex he
helps me run Toronto dance salsa which
is the largest salsa dance school in
Canada maybe North America and we're
sitting down reviewing his goals and
reviewing his habits and making sure
that you know what he said he was going
to do matches to him accomplishing his
goals and there are a couple things that
were big things on the list that he had
to get done and he was afraid of making
a mistake so for example we're trying to
create the interior of the studio and
make a wall that speaks to the purpose
of the company speaks to the the mission
the vision what we're trying to
accomplish and we want to have something
beautiful that people want to take their
pictures on and he's so afraid of
getting it right he's so afraid of doing
the wrong thing that he does nothing and
every time he opens up the file to look
at what he wants to do and different
ideas he's afraid he's going to make a
mistake he's afraid he's gonna invest
time energy dollars my money into
something that then when people show up
saying huh and it doesn't work out he's
so afraid to fail that he doesn't take
action which becomes the biggest failure
of all so here is our solution
procrastination Power Hour said every
day PPH
put it into your calendar for one hour
this is your PPH time the thing that you
have been procrastinated on right the
thing that serves the business if if
you've been procrastinating on it and
you don't like it and it doesn't serve
the business great get rid of it that's
not what we're talking about it's the
things that you're afraid of the things
that you don't want to make a mistake on
that you're just pushing aside because
there's all this busy work that comes in
because yes we have to respond to
customers and yes we got to do all the
work that goes into the day-to-day of
running the company
but if you're so focused on just the
day-to-day and never focus on the things
that will actually help you grow the
bigger picture stuff then guess what
happens you never do the bigger picture
stuff especially if it's because you're
afraid then you have to take action so
we plan the daily procrastination Power
Hour that he puts into his calendar and
he looks at it when he gets there he
thinks what am I procrastinating the
most on and he's got this list and he
starts attacking it and having that in
his calendar is the thing that actually
started building momentum for those big
projects rule number seven be bold what
would the boldest version of you do
think about your mission think about
your goals think about what you are
trying to accomplish you've got what
you're doing now but think about what
the boldest version of you if you summon
the boldest version of you into
existence right now what would he or she
tell you to do so when I did my tour
earlier this year it was 90 days 23
cities and at first I want to do it for
free I love doing free coffee shop
meetups every time I travel to a new
city and I told my agent Steve from New
York hey man this is my idea he said you
need to charge for the event you got to
play bigger you gotta you gotta do a
bolder version of you and it it's
freaked me out it scared me because I
don't want to disappoint people in the
idea of charging for something and then
me disappointing people and then hitting
that fear every four days because I got
up in a new city every three to four
days for 90 days was me being able to
conquer my fears and so Steve pushed me
and I have Steve's voice in my head it's
like you need to play bigger you got I
do something Bolder what's the next step
and so I'm looking at my next tour
coming up in 2020 around my book built
the serve and I'm trying to think how do
I make it even bigger how do I make it
even Bolder because what I've done has
been great and it's not trying to take
away from what I've done it's amazing
I'm proud of myself I'm grateful awesome
and I know I'm capable of more and I
know I need to do something at the next
level because if I want to go off and
accomplish my mission I need to because
at the rate I'm going right now I'm not
going to hit a billion people I'm not
going to solve the world's biggest
problem
I'm not gonna have the impact and reach
that I know I can have unless I demand
more boldness bigger scale from myself
on a daily basis and so for me having
Steve's voice in my head having Elon
musk's voice in my head having Steve
Jobs and apagenini and my parents and
Kanye West and Howard Schultz constantly
in my head the content that I make is
for myself
it's selfish for myself and then I share
with you guys and thankfully you like it
so I could build a business around it
and hire your team and keep creating
more
what makes you bold what makes you come
alive and how do you summon that
creature on a daily basis when you if
you wake up and you daily every day
consistently are bringing the boldest
version of you even for one year if you
woke up every day for one year and
summoned the boldest version of you your
life is gonna look dramatically
different one year from today rule
number eight Feel the fear and do it
anyway
stop thinking that you
that you Fearless
if you are playing small and not doing
anything that is worth doing you should
be dreaming big you should be pushing
boundaries and in that push comes fear
instead of trying to be Fearless adopt
the mindset that you want to feel the
fear and do it anyway otherwise you will
never tick on big projects and you'll
never accomplish your mission and you'll
always live below the potential that you
know you're capable of rule number nine
ask for help not asking for help is
selfish you might think that trying to
do everything yourself is selfless that
it's wrong to ask for help and Noble to
do everything yourself but you love
helping people you love helping others
remember that Joy you feel when you help
somebody and write a smile to their face
knowing you made their week by you not
asking for help you're cheating people
of that opportunity to bring a smile to
their face stop being selfish and start
asking for help I came up with this idea
when I was at a video game Cafe so
here's what happened I was I was on a
call with one of my big customers at the
time and I was in Los Angeles and we're
doing a Google live streaming to my
YouTube channel lots of people watching
YouTube live I'm interviewing him and
then the internet goes down like what
happened the power went out across all
of Los Angeles the power goes out and it
and it's down I got nothing the stream
is still live but I'm not there anymore
I left my client live on the stream and
he's he's not sure what happens he just
sees my camera go down and then he keeps
going by himself for another 15-20
minutes waiting for me to come back and
he's he's embarrassed and it's awkward
and he doesn't know what he's doing
because the host who has the audience
there is now gone and then eventually he
just leaves because he said well I don't
know where Evan is but
thank you guys for watching and it put
him in a really difficult situation I
felt terrible I went back to watching
another live stream after like oh my God
I can't believe that happened now it's
out of my control like you know the
internet goes down in Los Angeles what
am I supposed to do there's no power
anywhere so as soon as the power gets
back up I message my my client and say
hey man
I'm really sorry about that let's
reschedule it let's do it again when I'm
back home in Toronto where I know I have
stable internet and and I want to do it
again for free no extra cost uh even
though we had almost finished the live
stream together we're gonna do a whole
other one for free just because I want
you to I want to make this right for you
great so we come back to Toronto it's
like a week or two later and my internet
is pretty Rock Solid in my home office
I've never had an internet issue really
happen while I was doing a live stream
but I wanted to make extra sure extra
sure that this time nothing happened
because if something happened the second
time
just it would not be a good thing so I
asked my friend J rise and said J rise I
need I need a place that has Rock Solid
internet that I'm gonna do this live
stream and nothing can go wrong
and he said I got a place as an internet
cafe that got that I go to I'll
introduce you to the owner I know him
and and you can do it there like thank
you so much so we go there I'm there an
hour early I'm setting up I'm talking to
the owner I'm testing the gear my
microphone the headset all of it the
camera testing all of it just to make
sure that everything is working smoothly
I'm nervous because the last time it
failed on us my client comes on we go
live for half an hour an hour I don't
remember and it was smooth perfect no
issues crisp amazing internet blazing
fast speeds great time with the audience
and we delivered an awesome product
sigh of relief right I'm so pumped I go
talk to the owner and say dude thank you
man it was perfect no complaints no
problems thank you so much how much do I
owe you
and he said well you are on the computer
for about an hour and a half and j-rod
is on the computer for about an hour and
a half but I'll just bundle it together
so
I think what he told me was like five
bucks or seven bucks or ten bucks or
something like are you kidding me I
would have paid a thousand dollars I
would have paid a lot of money just to
make sure that this went smoothly
because it's the it's the relationship
with my client at the time right I said
okay well let me great here's here's the
seven dollars that you wanted awesome
let me buy let me buy some some stuff
from behind the counter let me buy some
snacks from my friend Jerry Rice jairo's
was hungry he needed to eat so like here
here's 20 bucks 25 bucks let me just buy
out a whole bunch of your snacks and
give it to him he's like no no you don't
have to do that man don't worry about it
like no I want to do it let me buy the
snack no no don't worry about it
the owner thought that he was doing a
good thing the owner thought that he was
being selfless that hey don't worry but
you don't have to do it that just just
paying for the internet was enough for
him but he was actually being selfish
in that moment he was being selfish
because he cheated me of the opportunity
of one saying thank you I wanted to pay
more I want to pay more you're cheating
me of the opportunity to do it and
you're cheating me of the opportunity to
help my friend J rise and give him some
food because he was hungry so we had to
go somewhere else you need to be willing
to bring other people in you need to be
willing to ask for help
yes you don't want to waste your time
yes you want to be respectful yes but
people love helping others we are built
to serve you want to help other people
that joy that you feel when you help
somebody out
allow it to come into other people's
hearts too and Rule Number 10 the last
one before a very special bonus clip is
don't quit on what you love if you quit
on something too soon that you still
love you will regret it for the rest of
your life if you don't love it anymore
quit move on you will never win doing
work that you hate but if you love it
you love it and you move on to something
else you will look back on this day and
regret it for the rest of your life that
you did not see it through most people
spend their entire life living with
regrets don't let that be you the
hardest decision I ever had to make in
my life was being an entrepreneur I
struggled a lot with the decision do I
want to be an entrepreneur and had this
opportunity to make 300 a month and earn
30 of a company versus going to work at
a job that I thought I wanted a job that
I've been preparing myself for that this
is what I wanted to do was in my high
school yearbook of this is where I was
going to be and here it was earning six
figures traveling around the world doing
the investment banking I thought I
wanted to do versus making 300 a month
and only only and owning 30 percent of a
company and the thing that allowed me to
push through and be an entrepreneur was
me saying I don't want to live with
regret
that I would rather no one fail than not
know
and I gave myself a year I said I'm
going to give myself a year to do this I
could always go back and get another job
it may not be the same job it probably
wouldn't be the same job may not be as
much pay may not be traveling as much as
this job was offered for me to travel
but this entrepreneurial thing this
opportunity that I had
I never knew if it would come back again
like I thought maybe this will never
happen to me again and so I decided to
go for it and we struggled and and it
was hard but I never ended up having to
go back and get another job
and so if you're at an inflection point
if you're thinking about which path
should I take a or b
lean in with your heart stop using your
head your head only understands the
world that currently exists lean in with
your heart
and ask yourself which decision will I
regret more if I don't do and then go
take that action
I became an entrepreneur because I
didn't want to regret not having at
least tried and a great moment in my
life came a number of years later but
one of the people I went to University
with came back and said Evan
I went down that path I became the
investment banker
and I hate my life how do I become an
entrepreneur
and I looked in his eyes and I saw the
desperation and the sadness and helped
him but also was so grateful that that
wasn't me because it could have been
you are what you consistently do it's
not what you do some of the times it's
not what you do when you feel motivated
or you had enough sleep or that it's the
perfect conditions out there you are
where you consistently do the one-off
moments don't mean anything you can have
a chocolate bar but if the rest of your
days are eaten healthy all the time
guess what you're not going to gain a
ton of weight and likewise the other way
around if you have a life that you're
not following through on any of your
goals and then you have one great moment
or one great day guess what you fall
back down
this is where a lot of entrepreneurs
struggle because you have these moments
where you feel alive empowered on top of
the world amazing and you might even put
a little bit of that into practice but
if it's not consistent
then it never happens and it's almost
better to not even know what you're
capable of this is the part of the curse
of being an entrepreneur is you know
you're capable of great things you see
an amazing future amazing world of what
you could build
but then you also see your lack of
follow-through and the lack of delivery
and the lack of execution and it's that
constant grind against your self-worth
to say I should be doing more but I'm
not it's almost better to have no goals
and have no dreams and have no ambition
because then you're good then you're in
in Bliss because you're ignorant of
what's what you're capable of
so how do you fix it I look at myself
and anytime I want to make a change in
my life it goes to the schedule
my schedule has to map to my ambitions
right your schedule needs to map to your
missions what you say you wanted a life
needs to be in your life
right hope is not is not enough hoping
that you have enough inspiration hoping
that you get motivated hoping that
you'll be ready one day that's not
enough it's not a day of the week right
some day is not it's not a day of the
week Sunday is but someday is not a day
of the week and so whatever you wanted a
life has to be in your calendar whatever
success looks like for you how finances
relationships whatever it looks like for
you whatever that perfect vision is in
your head whatever you have on your
dream board of what you want to
accomplish in your life okay great how
do you accomplish that how do you get
there it's your habits success is habits
success equals habits
where are your habits in your calendar
so what are you doing
when you wake up in the morning what are
you doing every single day of the week
what are you doing for planning for your
for you know the the quarter and the
week and the even the year ahead what
are you doing what are you doing to
change what's in your calendar to make
sure that if you actually did those
things like if you look at your week
look at your next week
look at what's in your calendar
your health goals your your relationship
goals not just the goals but the
execution against it you can say you
want to have a great body or you want to
get healthy this year great what does
that look like where in your calendar
are you spending time planning your food
and working out and taking care of
yourself it has to be a time not just
not just a blank space this is the
problem we'll book a lot of our business
stuff but not our personal stuff I book
all my personal stuff my time with Nina
is in my calendar the time to celebrate
with the kids and families in the
calendar it's in the calendar it's as
important as a business meeting because
what happens is when you have blank
spots in your calendar
you start living an unintentional life
right when you set up a calendar and you
create the blocks of time for where
you're going to spend when you're going
to wake up and what you're going to work
on and when you're going to take care of
your body and when you're going to take
care of your relationships or take care
of self
right if when that's in your calendar
that's living an intentional life
when you just have a bunch of blank
spots
you get distracted pull up your phone
and dive into Instagram and three hours
later you're still on it and you feel
worse about yourself so it's about
creating an intentional life for
yourself and that starts with your
calendar you are what you consistently
do you are what you repeatedly do so how
do we do it how are some of the steps
what what are the three action items for
you well step one is to figure out what
do you want
especially on a belief scale like what
do you want to believe
what is the difference between where you
are now and where you want to go and
this can be hard for Achievers because
you probably
are the most ambitious person that you
know right you're the one who's caring
about other people you're the one
encouraging on the people but nobody's
doing it for you so what are the beliefs
that you need to have what's the most
important belief change that you need to
have that you're not getting from your
immediate circle doesn't mean you stop
pointing to the people keep doing that's
amazing you're built to serve it's going
to fill you up but you need something to
pour into you otherwise you don't grow
right if you're just feeding other
people and nothing's feeding you you
don't grow you're just gonna get drained
so what's going to be feeding into you
the belief
that would make the difference between
where you are right now and where you
want to be what is that single belief
great so getting clear on what that one
don't don't worry about having a hundred
different beliefs yet tackle one thing
at a time what's the single most
important belief that you need to have
for yourself to get your next level of
growth great step number two
who is doing that right now
who was doing that and creating an
environment and habits around it so for
me I want to believe in myself more I
want to spread more belief to other
people as well so what's in my
environment well my physical environment
you can see here from me wearing this
outfit to having you know the pictures
behind me on the wall these people all
inspire me for different reasons to the
videos that I make and consume to the
work that I do in my community to the
new Discord that I set up Evan
carmichael.biz if you want to come and
join us uh that's part of what I do
every day to make me feel like I believe
in myself more believe in in me as a
human believe in the work that I'm doing
believe that it will work out I want
more belief and I've designed habits and
rituals to help me get it where most
people again do not wake up and feel
like today is going to be an amazing day
and they're just bursting full of energy
and on top of the world from the moment
they wake up no I woke up this morning
it was just past seven
um I don't sleep to an alarm so I woke
up and just I wake up when my body tells
me to wake up so I woke up just past
seven
um I didn't know what day it was you
know I'm tired I wake up I go to the
bathroom and on my way I put on an oldie
song and and all these music gets me
moving gets me bouncing gets me jiving
and then immediately start going to
community stuff right I'm in the
bathroom I'm listening to my oldies I
look at my intention for the day today
I'm recording YouTube videos how do I
want to show up what I want to do who do
I want to be showing up on the content
and then go to community
and I go I joined my Discord and I'm
giving love to people because it makes
me feel like what I do matters and it
makes me feel more belief right I've got
videos on that everybody remind me of
who I want to be I'm around my heroes
and mentors but deciding
the difference that you need to believe
between now and where you're going and
then two putting it into your calendar
especially the morning routine of how
you're going to show up so it's not an
accident so that you don't hope that
that you show up and you do it today but
that it's it's marked in your calendar
and in step three and this is the
hardest for a lot of people is you do
what's in your calendar here's a really
important rule that if you do this it
will change your life
when you are deciding
what to do in your calendar on the day
of
you cannot change what's in today's
calendar you can change tomorrow's but
you can't change today's here's what I
mean if you're looking at your calendar
and you set out your goals right here
here's who I want to be this week here's
what I want to get done this week I want
to wake up at this time and I want to
work out and I want to connect with my
family and I want to serve and whatever
whatever the chunks of time are for you
there's a tendency to in the moment
change
where on Sunday you looked at your
calendar and said here's what I'm going
to do this is going to be an exciting
week it's great but then come Thursday
morning you don't want to wake up at
that time or you see what's in the
calendar I don't want to go for that run
I don't want to make those calls I don't
want to make those videos and then you
don't and you quickly fall off track
sound familiar is it making sense it
looks so great on the weekend when you
plan this but now when you're actually
doing it you don't do it
and then what happens is the next time
you say you're going to do something you
don't believe yourself because you let
yourself off the hook too easily so the
rule becomes you can only change
tomorrow's calendar not today you're
tired
you had a rough day
you don't think this workout's working
for you anymore you don't think making
videos is aligned with you anymore great
tomorrow you don't have to do it
tomorrow you can change but today you're
doing it because you said you were gonna
do it tomorrow you can sleep in because
today you had a last night you had a
rough night so today you're extra tired
but you're still getting up when you
said you're gonna get up and you still
do the things that are in your calendar
and then tomorrow you can sleep in and
tomorrow you can adjust
the workout the business plan whatever
if it doesn't feel right anymore but not
today don't trust yourself in the moment
because your brain is going to tell you
to play small your brain is going to
remind you why you can't do these things
your brain is going to find a reason for
you to let yourself off the hook again
like it did last time
you know what you want
that's what you said you were going to
do on the weekend when you look at your
calendar
you have to show up the day of
so you have to get really clear on the
belief that you want to have that will
make the difference for you you need to
surround yourself with those Heroes and
role models and change your morning
routine to reflect it and then you need
to actually do what's in your calendar
and if something's off or it doesn't
work you change it for tomorrow but you
can't change it in the moment you are
what you consistently do
you know you've got so much inside you
and so much that you want to share and
serve and help
and you keep letting yourself down
and it's it's time to change it
you're ready to change it you're ready
to move past it you're ready to be the
person who follows through you're ready
to be the person who with that big dream
starts to make momentum towards it
the only difference is being the person
who does what you consistently say you
will do you've got a great idea
you know it can change the world you
know it could have a big impact you know
it could change the fortunes of yourself
your family the people around you you've
got a great idea you know what can work
you know it can work
the problem is you don't know if it can
work for you you believe in the idea but
you don't believe in yourself and so
here's what's happened why well it's
because you've tried and stopped and
started and stopped and started and
stopped and you maybe saw a little bit
tiny results but then you lose the
motivation and and you stop you've never
stayed with anything long enough to
actually let it see results and so you
built up this pattern inside yourself
that says I can't do it the idea is
great but I can't do it that's really at
the core if you really believe that you
could do it and you really believed in
the idea you'd be doing it and crushing
it so it's the biggest difference is why
lack of belief is the world's biggest
problem the only thing you're missing is
actual sustained momentum against your
ideas because if you believe that you
could do it you'd be out there doing it
you believe in your idea
and how it could change the world but
you don't believe in your own abilities
to do it
now this is where we have to start
talking about making decisions with your
head versus your heart
so your head only understands a world
that exists your head is logical it's
practical and so whatever's been done
can be done again right it's logical and
so if you've got a job at some company
you know you can make X thousands of
dollars a year that's that's safe that's
logical that's practical you know what
can be done it exists other people have
done it too
you compound that with people telling
you to do the safe thing right go get a
job go take the safe path go take the
safe route and so there's a lot of
outside forces especially fear generated
that keep you on a small path keep you
on the safe path and it's not
necessarily wrong it's not malicious
they're not trying to hurt you
it's just fear-based and so it's small
you never create amazing things when
you're living in a fear-based state and
that's what you're doing when you make
big decisions with your head because
your head only understands a practical
world that currently exists
now your heart your heart's a different
story your heart can create something
that's never existed before your heart
is where all the artists lives all the
all the game changers live all the
people who end up making massive change
in the world that's where they live
they're creating something new they say
I see something that other people don't
see and I can go create it that's heart
you're creating something that hasn't
existed before that doesn't make sense
that's not logical that's not practical
there's nothing to tell you that this
could work but you feel that it can work
that's where I know you guys are at if
you're watching this channel you're
watching this video that's where I know
you're at the problem is living inside
your head instead of living inside your
heart
so what happens is you'll have some days
where you're living in your heart you
have some days when you feel bold
motivated excited feeling like you're
capable like maybe you could actually do
this you'll have some days I'm gonna
switch my hand my hand's getting tired
I'm holding the video you'll have some
days where you'll actually feel that way
like maybe I can I can be the person I
am bold maybe you watch a video maybe
just wake up and you get inspired you
had a great dream something happens you
have this moment where you just feel
bold powerful and stopper and say
today's my day I'm gonna go off and do
it and crushing right we've all had
those moments
but then you wake up the next day and
you're back to being in your head
telling yourself I can't do this I
didn't go to school for this I don't
have the money for this I don't have the
talent for this I'm not good enough for
this I'm I'm not brave enough or
creatures enough for this right that's
all you're ahead talking to yourself
when you haven't fully decided
on something big what ends up happening
is you're heading your heart fight
so if you haven't fully decided that you
want to start this business that you
want to hit your 10 million subscribers
on YouTube that you want to fill in a
blank your big crazy ambitious goal when
you haven't fully decided on it your
head and your heart are going to fight
they should fight
because it's not logical it's not safe
it's not practical if it was it wouldn't
be a big idea your big amazing bold
ideas are not logical they're not
practical and they're not safe
as your head is always going to say whoa
whoa whoa slow down this is scary
and most of the time you're gonna listen
to your head and the people around you
will tell you listen to your head
what you need to do is fully decide what
you need to do is decide that this is
going to happen that it's not an option
anymore that there's no maybe I'll do it
maybe I won't your heart has to decide
the big decisions in your life should
you go move to that other country or
other City should you go marry that
person or not should you go take that
job or not should you go start that
business or not big decisions with your
heart and then you use your head to help
you figure out the how
I always find it so funny when people
are thinking well should I do that
business or not or should I marry that
person or not and they make a they make
a list or make a checklist
and you write down pros and cons right
never make a decision that's big in your
life based off of objective pros and
cons because you're making it using the
wrong part of your body
because you might really love somebody
and you come with all these lists and
you got
80 80 cons on that list and only one pro
or maybe that one pro is all you need
same thing with the business there's a
million reasons why your business is not
going to work out you sit there and make
a list of of pros and cons there should
be way more cons there's a million
reasons why you're not going to win and
eight why you will and the people who go
off and win only focus on the eight
making a list of pros and cons to help
you make big decisions in life is one of
the stupidest things you can do
straight up
now your head is very important
your head
helps you accomplish your goals but only
once your heart's decided
so your heart allows you to make the big
decisions I want this to happen in my
life no negotiation this is going to
happen
and then from there you use your head to
figure out how to do it
right once your head is not fighting
your heart once your head is understood
oh
he's serious she's serious okay crap how
did we actually make this happen now
that's when you use your head because
you're a smart person and you need your
head aligned to help you accomplish your
big goals so if I want to go off and
build my YouTube channel and get 10
million subscribers that's happening
when I first started YouTube 11 years
ago there was no educational content
there were no 15 minute videos on
YouTube it was it was all memes and and
stupid videos and cats and
not this not this at all
and it took me too long to listen to my
heart quite frankly you know I loved it
and so I kept doing it and and you know
part of my own back for myself was that
thankfully I kept going I wasn't as
consistent as I am now but I kept going
I didn't give up even though there were
no signs that I would have success right
my first video got three comments in one
year and one was my mom one was my
sister and one was some random dude I
wasn't getting traction
I'll still looking back at some of my
old videos yesterday and a lot of them
no no comments right like one video 35
views zero comments man I can spend a
lot of time making that video
and so I kept going
because there was something inside me
that said I need to keep doing this
I wish I kept going faster and it's my
wish for you too right now with your
business with your idea with your crazy
goals I wish you keep going but I wish
you'd go faster on it that you decide
with your heart to say I am making this
happen
and you say head listen to me we're
making this happen now you're the smart
one
help me figure out how to actually do it
so to get to my 10 million subscribers
how do I do it
and every day I'm using my brain to help
me do it and hopefully you are too
when your head and your heart are
fighting when your goals your Ambitions
your dreams are fighting every day what
you think is practical logical possible
you're just gonna be stuck
very slow growth very some momentum
knowing you're capable of more but just
stuck because you're fighting yourself
the biggest problem is you're just
fighting yourself but when you can let
go when you can say my heart is going to
help me make the big decisions in my
life
and my head's gonna help me figure out
how magical things start to happen and
that's my wish for you self-confidence
comes from doing difficult things
self-confidence self-love self-respect
it all comes from deciding to do
something difficult
here's what happens when when something
hard comes up and you find a reason why
you can't do it
it's too hard it's too difficult it's
too scary
most people let you off the hook
people around you will say yeah yeah
that's way too hard I mean the fact you
even thought about it was crazy
you let yourself off the hook
but then you realize
done it you know like that's the worst
feeling in the world that you could have
done something
but then you came up with an excuse as
to why you can't
and that will eat you up
and even if the world lets you off the
hook
recognize that they have lower standards
than you
recognize that the people who are giving
you that advice and patting on the back
and saying it's okay you don't need to
do it they don't like their life either
they're stuck they're trapped
they're not pushing hard they're not
being aggressive for their goals they're
not tough either
and we're reinforcing that Comfort Loop
every day comfort you versus growth you
are in a fight there's a war going on
inside you comfort you versus growth you
comfort Evan birth is growth Evan every
day there's a fight there's a battle
there's a war going on and you need to
decide who's gonna win the fight
it's a daily thing and the more growth
you wins against comfort you the more
you start to grow the more you start to
hit your goals the more you start to
have an impact the more you start to
love yourself
[Music]
because again even if the world would
let you off the hook
you know it's just an excuse
I think most people think of it as a
giant step that you have to take to
build that self-confidence it's not I
think it's much more about the daily
battles with yourself that then builds
up to Major things just like you don't
go to the gym and lift 400 pounds you
start by lifting five pounds or ten
pounds or 20 pounds or 40 pounds
whatever it is that's how you start to
build the muscle it's much more about
the Daily building of the muscle to show
yourself who you are much more than the
one-off heroic moments here's an example
so uh yesterday we had an insane
snowstorm here in Toronto I don't know
if we can it's kind of blurry you can't
see we had like you see some here behind
me it's like looking see that mountain
of snow behind me we had an insane
snowstorm we had probably the worst
snowstorm in Toronto Canada in the
decade I have not seen this much snow in
a crazy amount of time and so I'm going
for a walk
uh rocking and rucking is where you
carry a backpack so I'm carrying a
backpack of 20 pounds
as I'm walking doing my normal walk and
it's it's crazy outside normally the
rucking alone is hard enough and I just
increased the weight in the backpack now
I there's no path to walk on and this
morning I was walking through an area
and there was Zero path the snow is up
to my knees and I need to get through
so what's what are my options well I
could I could complain and turn around
right like I could look out the window
and say ah so much snow I'm not gonna do
that I'll do it when there's less snow
you know and then the next day there's
less snow there's still snow in the next
it's still snow and then all of a sudden
you just gave up on the Habit right like
you let yourself off the hook to say
I'll do it tomorrow and then and then
you never do it and then the habit's
gone and that's what you're teaching
yourself this is why it leads to
Identity this is why it leads to
negative self-worth and negative
self-confidence because the next time
you come up with an idea you've already
reinforced the training you're training
yourself that when you come up with an
idea you don't do the thing when you say
you're gonna do it and you're gonna
start tomorrow and then you don't the
next time you come up with an idea guess
what you you've already reinforced the
pattern I don't follow through I'm not
gonna do that I'm excited today but
tomorrow I won't follow through
so there's a snow is up to my knees
right up to my knees and I'm six one so
it's it's some serious snow like I gotta
walk through not quite that that's
that's probably taller than me uh I
don't have to walk through that much but
but up to my knees
I'm looking at it and I've got to go I
don't know
100 meters
through this thing
and initially my thought was oh man why
is there no path why is nobody shoveled
this why is nobody still upload this
like gotta get over there I got a
backpack on I'm rocking I'm sweating
like crazy I'm already exhausted now I
gotta go through this
this is when we need to catch ourselves
right everybody would have let me off
the hook
and another me would have let me off the
hook right Comfort Evan would have let
growth happen off the hook so it's okay
go back home
or go the long way around where there's
a path don't go through that snope to
your knees
and as soon as I caught it
now what
most of the time you won't catch it most
of the time you'll just do
you'll do the automatic thing and
usually the automatic thing is is the
comfort thing so usually play small by
default usually you you'll look outside
and see the snow and not go just by
default not even catching the the
conversation with yourself
but when you catch it
this is a really important moment what
do you do do you do the difficult thing
or do the comfort thing
because when you catch it and you make a
conscious choice this is how we start to
either change our Identity or reinforce
our identity
so I looked at it I caught it and said
I'm going through let's go you know I
caught the negative thinking I caught
the Comfort Evan coming over walk around
go home nope not happening we're going
through we are going through we're gonna
make it through
and it was rough
you know I'm walking through I'm
freezing uh I'm taking one kind of giant
step at a time snow is getting all
through my boots all down my legs I I
almost slip and fall I have a coffee
that I that I picked up uh it's dripping
all over the place
and in my head as I'm going through it
it's like this is the best let's go
let's go Evan you got this man let's go
you do difficult things that's the thing
on repeat in my head
combined with that
I'm also telling myself that you know
what not only am I doing this difficult
thing for me I'm also creating the path
for other people that the next person
who comes up against this 100 meters or
so that now they will have not an easy
time but an easier time of crossing the
same path
so they can get across
so it's going to service
if you're ever having a hard time
getting yourself to do something
it's one you do difficult things remind
yourself and two default the service
that it's not just about you it's for
other people now that may not even be
true
maybe nobody ever comes across that path
maybe I didn't make it easier for the
next person maybe somebody comes five
minutes after me and snow blows the
whole thing and so there was Zero
service
it doesn't matter it's the story that
I'm telling myself that it will serve
other people that will get you to then
do the difficult thing
so in order to make it happen
there's two triggers that I use one is
language so scary difficult or hard if
you say those things if you feel those
things if you text those things if you
write those things if you're talking to
yourself and you catch those things then
you have to do it you can no longer
accept scary difficult or hard as
reasons for you not to do the thing
because your great life is on the other
side of scary difficult heart everything
you want the business you want the
relationships you want the help that you
want everything everything your great
life if you wrote down a list of
everything you want out of life
everything on that list comes on the
other side of you doing scary difficult
and hard things
growth you that's growth you fighting
comfort you
so when you catch yourself sane speaking
writing thinking scary difficult to
heart that's a that's a trigger it
should be a trigger it's a trigger for
me it should be a trigger for you to go
and do it do it go walk through the
giant snow and you might be thinking
well how does that help me with my
business it's just walking through snow
and I'm going to be cold and have snow
in my boots how does that help me
it's an identity thing
because as soon as you start to teach
yourself that you're the kind of person
who follows through on those scary
difficult hard things
then the next time that shows up
anywhere in your life in your business
and your relationships and your health
anything that actually helps you
accomplish your goals you're going to be
ready to show up for it you're going to
be more likely to actually do the thing
because you've been training and
conditioning yourself to do the thing
that's why walking through 100 meters of
snow matters
so the first is scary difficult hard
those are verbal cues or thought cues
the second is the boom boom boom test
where your heart is beating quickly it's
like when your heart is going crazy like
that
it's usually because you should be doing
something you're afraid right now don't
again go don't go don't go standing on
the highway uh because it's scary and it
makes your heart race right don't be
stupid but most of the things that
you're afraid of
aren't actually things that are going to
be life-threatening
right they're not they're usually it's
other people's opinions usually you're
afraid of not failing but somebody
watching you fail right you're gonna
fail at something who's gonna see you
that's what we're actually afraid of and
that cannot be a good enough reason it
can't not anymore if you're afraid of
losing in front of somebody if you're
afraid of other people's opinions if you
are living your life based off of the
expectations and Judgment of other
people you will never do anything great
you will never live your great life
because somebody always has a plan for
what you should be doing with your life
you will never please everybody it's not
possible
you have to start to learn to please
yourself and it's not doing something
just to show off and just to prove
somebody wrong I'm not a big fan of
tapping into that energy the reason to
do something is not to prove somebody
wrong and make somebody else look stupid
the reason to do something is because
that's who you are and that's what you
want to do
and so learning to do difficult things
teaching yourself step by step Brick by
Brick one snow storm at a time
teaching yourself that
will change your life
you deserve a better life
you deserve a great life
when that comes on the other side of you
doing the things that are scary
difficult and hard if you think money is
scarce you hoard it because you believe
that no more money will come to you
if you know money is abundant more money
will flow to you this isn't about being
wasteful doesn't it doesn't mean you
have to go and always empty your pockets
and buy a lot of dumb stuff and throw
away all your other stuff it doesn't
mean you have to waste your money
but it's switching the mindset of money
is not just some scarce thing that you
don't know how to make that you will
never have more of and so you need to
hoard every single dollar that you've
got
this is honestly something that I am
continuing to rewire myself on I
struggled a lot with money especially in
the early days of my business
um even growing up I grew up in a middle
class family my parents spent my parents
are behind me on the wall hold on there
we go this is me when I'm eight or nine
and my parents here they believed in
education a lot and they didn't have a
ton of money we weren't poor but they
spent all of their money basically on
putting the three of us kids I have two
sisters through private school so any
money that they made basically poured
into our education and as a result we
didn't have you know money for other
things and
um where my friends at these fancy
schools were getting you know BMWs for
their 16th birthday so they can go off
and drive uh you know I didn't get any
of that and it's not what was me but
it's more I just had a scarce mentality
around money in my first business I was
making 300 bucks a month I was eating
the same bean salad lunch every day
because it would fill me up and wasn't
very expensive
when we celebrated a win we'd go to
McDonald's if we got a new client like
hey we sold another piece of our
software we go to McDonald's and Order
large fries and share that between the
three of us because it was cheap and we
wanted just some little way to celebrate
and
I just remember how painful it was to
feel like you have no money and you
can't buy stuff and I couldn't hang out
with my friends and I couldn't do what I
wanted to do and I think that has a
traumatic effect you know I mean maybe
that's you as well you you have a
scarcity mindset around money that you
don't know how to make it and so
anything you've got you got to really
hold on to it and protect it
and again I'm not advocating for being
Reckless or stupid or just throwing
money away be smart about how you're
going to invest and use your money the
more important thing is developing the
mindset that you can
create money that by bringing a lot of
value to people you can make more money
you can turn it into something
so one of the things that I've done
recently that that has helped both
myself and Nina my wife is we create
what we call a care fund
and every month when we're doing our
numbers
Nina will put together how much we've
made this month how much cash flows come
in ETC and then we allocate a certain
percentage for a care fund that we have
to go off and spend
uh either for ourselves or for other
people
and so my default is to invest invest
invest invest invest right like invest
back into the business invest into into
into markets invest in the assets just
invest invest invest invest invest
invest
the that's a good that's a great good
mindset the downside of that is you
don't get to see
the impact that it can create
and so said you know what we need to
dedicate a percentage every month to go
and help somebody else and maybe it's
help ourselves you know
um on the weekend Nina bought a very
expensive purse
we went shopping she had a very
offensive purse we bought a Chanel bag
and
probably more expensive than she's ever
bought a bag and for me it's like oh my
gosh you can't be spending this amount
of money on a bag
but it's worth
celebrating yourself so you know what
like we earned that we did so much work
in our business you can you can go and
afford that
we've also used the money to donate the
Charities we've also used the money to
uh support our family and things that
they needed or wanted in their lives and
it's something that we have to spend
every month
Nina asked hey can we just save it so we
can invest more and then that leads to
more in the future like no we're already
saving other money to do that like that
has to be spent every month and so where
we have to sit it might sound crazy we
have to sit down every month and figure
out how we're going to spend this money
because my default is not to go and
spend the default is to invest or just
to save
and so doing that it doesn't have to be
a big amount of money it could it could
be 100 bucks a month that you force
yourself to spend on making somebody
else's life better or even your own like
that thing that you would never buy for
yourself you know what I've worked hard
like I'm gonna buy it or you're gonna go
buy somebody a meal or you're gonna go
and give a homeless person 100 right
like you're gonna you're gonna do
something with it
because what it does it starts to change
your mentality around it it starts to
make you feel like
more will come
that I'm creating
and so whether it's 10 bucks 100 bucks a
thousand bucks 10 000 bucks like you
know whatever it is I'm not advocating
you go drain your bank account and just
go crazy and buy a Chanel bag you know
but allocating a certain percentage
every month
so that you can start to rewire your
beliefs around money that it's not just
super scarce so that would be step
number one right allocate some kind of
budget to helping especially others
because when you can when you help
others it just makes you feel so good
and you can help others in a lot of ways
you can help them with your time you can
help them with your expertise you can
help them you know not just give a man a
fish but teach them how to fish right
but there's there's the immediate
gratification of helping somebody buying
the coffee for the person behind you in
line or seeing somebody that you know
that that
25 bucks 100 bucks will make a big
difference and like you were able to
afford to do that
gives you the extra oomph to go off and
want to do more of it like if you know
that that 25 bucks change that person's
life imagine if you can give them 2500
bucks
but to do that you'd have to go off and
build a bigger business right so the the
core of your business needs to be
serving and helping and contributing
back and you can't afford yet to give
somebody 2500 bucks but you could if you
kept building your business and so it
just gives that little extra bit of
motivation and incentive right to get
out there and start to do it to allocate
a certain percentage second is to be
around people who are
who are generous be around the people
who have the mindset that you want to
have if there's a belief that you want
to adopt the fastest way to do it is to
be around the people who constantly are
screaming that belief the people who are
constantly living that belief so if you
love
my view on something great hanging
around me more often lots of videos you
love Grant cardone's view or garyvee's
view or Oprah's view on something the
more you hang around them and watch
their content and read their books and
listen to their speeches the more you're
going to start to adopt that same belief
system
so if you want to believe that money is
not scarce then you need to be hanging
around people who believe that money is
not scarce because probably the people
in your life believe money is really
scarce and the people that I grew up
with believe that money is really scarce
the closest people around me and so it
doesn't mean you stop hanging out with
them but you need to inject new people
in even if it's just through YouTube
videos other people who believe the
thing that you want to believe because
otherwise you get pulled back down
because your environment has been
created to keep you where you are so if
you want to change where you are you
have to change the environment and it
used to be that you had to you have to
really change you have to go somewhere
else you had to move out you had to find
a mentor to hang out with and have
coffee with consistently now you can do
it through through YouTube I've been
inspired by tons of mentors who have
never met
because of the content that I've learned
from them on YouTube
but it takes the effort and intention to
be consistently around it that this is
the belief system that you want to have
you need to create that habit for
yourself from the things that are on the
wall to the clothes that you wear to the
media that you're consuming every day
being intentional with that to say this
is this this is the belief system that I
want to have I recognize I'm not there
yet but this is this belief system I
want to have and I want to be around the
people who believe this to their core
because their belief in that thing is
stronger than your belief against it and
whoever's more confident wins
and so when you're around the people who
believe that thing so much they will
pull you towards them to start having
that similar belief system and then
everything starts to change
I think having a scarcity mindset is
extremely limiting
I've I've lived through really intense
versions of it I still feel like I'm
coming out of it
I've grown a lot compared to where I
used to be but still have a lot a long
ways to go I probably still have things
that I'm holding on to that I shouldn't
uh I probably still should be more
generous than I am
um and I'm I'm working through it as
well I might just be a little bit
further ahead on the curve definitely
compared to 19 year old Evan who thought
money was the most scarce thing in the
world
when you can learn to make that rewiring
happen that's how you start to change
your life
so if you look at the people around you
look at their beliefs especially around
money
and see what do they think and then see
where they're at in their life compared
to the people who have different beliefs
around money and where they're at who
would you rather be and you could be
there you could be that person
if you start to change your beliefs your
environment start to
help more people with it start to allow
the money to flow
because when you start to believe that
you can create a lot more money for
yourself
a lot of things start to change
[Music]
it's far in a video I want to celebrate
you most people start and don't finish
most people never actually follow
through most people say they want
something but they don't ever do the
work to actually get it but you're
different you are special believe Nation
you made it here all the way to the end
and I love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to watch another top 10 rules of
Evan Carmichael check out the video next
to me continue to believe I will see you
there the problem is people compare
themselves to others as a way to kick
themselves down you look at somebody
else who's done a lot more than you and
you say wow they're so much better than
me I can never do it